johnny depp may have had his final word
in court e.t has learned he won't be
asked to retake the stand by amber
heard's attorneys here's what we know i
didn't even care anymore at this moment
i was
he had already ripped my heart out the
50 million dollar defamation trial is
winding down and while depp could
potentially take the stand again this
week the request will not come from
herds legal team a source close to amber
heard tells e.t depp's testimony has
been irrelevant to the heart of this
case there's no reason to believe it
would be any different now it's quite an
emotional ride as well the source adds
calling depth back to the stand would be
as relevant to us as a bicycle to a fish
as for depp's legal team they're
bringing in someone from his past
kate moss dated the actor in the 90s
with the romance lasting for four years
now the model is set to testify by video
on wednesday but it won't be the first
time kate's been referenced in the trial
you see my little sister with her back
face
her back to the staircase
and johnny swings at her at one point in
heard's lengthy testimony she references
a rumor about the past relationship
which alleges depp once pushed moss down
the stairs
heard cites this rumor on the stand as
she describes an alleged altercation
between depp and her sister whitney in
my head instantly think of
kate moss and the stairs
and i
swung at him
and all of my relationship to date with
johnny
i hadn't landed a blow
and i
for the first time hit him also take a
look at depp's legal team in this moment
as one attorney pumps his fist while
amber testifies i don't hesitate i don't
wait i just in my head instantly think
of
kate moss and the stairs
and i
swung at him the excited gesture is
seemingly in reaction to heard
mentioning moss by name which opened the
door to have moss testify as a rebuttal
witness it should be noted moss has
never addressed the claim that depp
pushed her down the stairs
meanwhile the trial continues on monday
if you're not agreeing with what mr depp
has to say
you are no longer useful
heard's team calls a psychiatrist to
testify and he alleges depp exhibits
several traits associated with
narcissism poor self-control and rapid
mood states
is fragile
self-esteem thinking that
ms heard
was marrying him solely for his money
and his influence and that that was the
case was in my opinion very entitled
again i think the whole concept of abuse
is exploitative
[Music]